i'm a big fan of classic films and i
love westerns and often the story seems
to be an allegory for something bigger
like a virtue or a loyalty what do you
think is that the moral heart of this
story sacrificing service service of
others
and you know on the day loyalty
i mean nobody ran that's right nobody
ran nobody ran is that why you think it
is important to be told again
particularly in today's world i'm not
trying to give a message but if movies
can influence i mean valor loyalty
virtue sacrifice
humility
and all that stuff i think is always a
good
thing to remind everyone
after making this movie is there
something that has changed the way
you'll view the genre undoubtedly i i
mean for me i think
every time i watch a western from now on
i'm gonna know
i'm gonna have an inside look
as to what it took to make that you know
i'll definitely never look at the movie
where the genre the same i think after
having been part of it yeah what it
takes and the horses and that you know
everything's so
even the horses had their marks remember
yeah you know the horse has to hit the
market
and
to be a good writer what is it about the
genre or what can you do with the
metaphors in this kind of story that you
think makes it so enduring the
landscapes there's nothing to hide
behind so the actor really comes forward
and your humanity comes forward you know
in the desert you know who are you it's
the eye of god is very strong
you know so the movies are rich in
metaphor this is very very uh simple
story classic story
but antoine is very contemporary
cool stylish director so
i think i think that combination is
great it kind of sucks that we have to
point out the fact that your character
is so unique within a western but we do
we still have to talk about it because
she is right yeah i'd say so i mean that
was what struck me at first reading the
script because i wasn't expecting for
her to have
such a significant role in terms of
her involvement in the journey and the
outcome of this story haley's part is a
really good part for a woman yeah you
know she plays uh somebody in a very
very vulnerable situation but yet she
remains hardcore and then of course
everybody's been bringing up the
diversity thing and i think that antoine
and denzel deserve a lot of credit for
that i think that the fact that it's
never mentioned
and the fact that the way that they both
approached um
the idea of an african-american being a
lead in the western the fact that they
just consider it normal
set is a big message that they send the
magnificent seven with steve mcqueen
annual brenner that one's appealing to a
certain taking that theme and applying
it to the culture of that time
now we're taking it and applying it to
our time right now you know and for me
from the younger generation i never
thought about it in the beginning
because i'm like oh these are like the
guys i grew up with you know yeah and
that's you know it's natural i need more
than a few to help us fight what a bunch
of misfits we are
you